there are new signs this morning that
the Boeing 737 max will not be flying
passengers for a while the Federal
Aviation Administration met with foreign
regulators in Fort Worth yesterday to
discuss the Jets future following two
recent deadly crashes Kris Van Cleave
spoke to the FAA s Acting Administrator
he's at dallas-fort Worth International
Airport with more on this story Chris a
lot of people still very leery about
this plane even when it comes back into
operation what you learn
well good morning Gail in fact we have
new numbers about how concerned the
flying public is but as Dan Elwha was
making his case to the rest of the world
that they should essentially trust the
FAA when they say the 737 max is safe to
fly new numbers show the flying public
is leery of the airplane regardless of
what the FAA says what has to happen for
this plane to get back in the air we
have to finish our system safety
analysis there will be some test flights
that have to be done and when we're
convinced that the 737 max is safe to
fly again we will lift the prohibition
order are we close to that point we
don't have a timeline aviation
regulators from 33 countries where the
Boeing 737 max flies came to this FAA
facility in Fort Worth Thursday at a
closed-door meeting acting FAA
Administrator Dan Elwell laid out the
agency's plan for certifying the max as
safe some countries did not attend a
sign the max may start flying first in
the US while the world watches none of
us are going to lift the prohibition on
the 77 max until it's safe to do so but
a new study found only about one in five
people surveyed would definitely fly on
a 737 max in the first six months of its
return to service
roughly half said they'd be unlikely to
get on board so it's important that the
FAA doesn't regulate by survey right we
regulate we're in the last 10 years in
the United States 90 million flights
seven billion passengers carried with
one fatality but if the public doesn't
think the planes safe don't you need to
listen to that yes we need to be
concerned if the public is is concerned
about flight yes is that bothersome it's
bothersome but we can't respond
specifically to
that concern when it comes to setting
safety standards so the FAA says no time
line but it's getting increasingly
likely that we won't see the max
carrying passengers until possibly the
end of the summer even the fall Boeing
says it's still working on answering
information requests from the FAA about
the software the airlines say once
they're told they can fly it'll take
them four to six weeks to have the
planes ready to go
but Boeing is already working on its PR
strategy to rebuild trust in the plane
they've hired a big-time PR firm but it
sounds like they're gonna plan to lean
heavily on the pilots to build goodwill
with passengers which has some pilots
saying they're there for safety not to
be Boeing's arm-candy
I don't think I'd want to be arm candy
either Chris the the max remains
grounded until the fall perhaps you
mentioned meanwhile triple-a says three
and a four million people will fly over
this Memorial Day weekend
how will the grounding affect aircraft
operations now well so direct impact
will be fairly limited because the
airlines knew the plane would be out of
service and have pulled it from the
schedule the indirect impacts could be
it may have cost you more to book your
ticket because there were fewer seats
available because there are fewer planes
in service and I would expect the
flights to be a little bit more crowded
than they otherwise would have been and
keep in mind the predictions are more
people will be flying this year than
last year well grace thank you very much
Boeing's PR team has a real uphill
battle people are very leery the
American Airlines CEO and the United CEO
said they would be among the first
passengers to get on the max when it's
back I'm going to see a lot of people
fly it before I get on it again I
remember the US was one of the last
countries to take it out of service
which was very concerning after two
crashes so you're right you're right
Anthony they have a real uphill battle
indeed